[Music]
guess what
little bro hasn't left little bro hasn't
left
we got a new one he has been on a roll
lately we got a new one look he's
dressed like a boy
guys look at him he's trying guys
no no you don't know what underwear is
under there all right let's celebrate
first day
it's his dad's birthday
everything
I'm not upstairs his dad said all I want
for birthday date and is you just dress
like just dress like a just dress like
my son I love that he's like we're not
on speaking terms yeah even though you
live in his home so I don't have any
boys clothes so I had to take Sherman's
old clothes oh God he's wearing a time
all ill-fitting they're all way too big
we're going Title boxing shorts
a champion basket exactly
that's about seven years so I'm just
keeping this on record as a video to
Ivory this shouldn't you know
up in my house I don't have to off any
of these people I refuse to talk to
these [ __ ] and I'm just you know my
favorite dating videos are the ones
where he's like in a room complaining
and all you hear outside the door is a
family having a great time Merchants
laughing actually Mercia said the same
thing before the funniest part about
Dayton you always hear it is you always
hear somebody else having fun around him
in his periphery there's always always
some Joy happening around him and he's
never taking part in he's just isolating
himself with his glitter covered phone
case and his health burritos
we're just having a good old
time downstairs right on the back patio
in his defense he can't hear the joy
because of all the peanut butter in his
peanut butter ears you forgot about
peanut butter ears it's so disgusting
they're awesome
[Music]
oh my God they're having a literal hoe
down outside for his dad's birthday and
he's up there complaining listen to the
fun listen outside
okay that's really funny
oh my God and they're all singing along
and he's up there go pretending that he
that they're the problem
everyone's having fun except him
this is just
one of my favorites
no Yuki relax
my sister
yeah he did he I hate them
over twice my size was beating in this
house repeatedly he has been dead for
like two years two years two years get
over it after the memory stays alive so
bad he was an Xbox one it was a really
crazy Xbox okay if this is a diary that
someone is reading Anne Frank somebody
would have read all of this stuff before
you're just repeating yourself like
you're in The Shining
to Donald Trump he's transfrank
yeah he had a ballist point pen
to exterminate all the blacks
who wanted to extreme all blacks and
Muslims Sherman was best friend with his
with both of your guys's sisters black
husband what are you talking about they
used to hang out together
dude everyone other than you Jaden is
seems to be lovely seems to be normal
lovely people especially considering
that they live in Dayton Ohio I know I'd
be miserable your family should even be
even more trash than they are but for
Dayton they're actually pretty quality
folks they really are you know
apparently I have that stated right on
video when I recorded I'm like I think I
have over 200 hours or something of a
footage honestly dude
of course they don't but but no but but
you know but I used to think that too
but like
you know merch and I have said this for
after a while like after year one we're
like okay but this is their fault they
could kick them out
like his parents can file an eviction
notice and kick him out in 60 days if
they wanted to and they're not yeah so
they they're doing I mean yeah partly
they're enabling because you know it's
one it's you know after one time you use
your credit card okay but you keep
members use his credit card he used all
the aluminum foil in the house to make
his artwork in the Attic
he did yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] shaken flake over here
has been ruining their life like
they just allowed him to do [ __ ]
panko hypernova yeah seriously thank you
Yeah clean the house and do the laundry
how do you clean when you leave the dust
bro we've actually seen videos of him
sweeping up his dead skin from the floor
it is just oh come on man gusting
in the same it looks like him sweeping
up beachfront property it really does
it looks it really does look like he's
just [ __ ] he's [ __ ] uh he's he's
sweeping up after this is merch after he
accidentally tips over his a kitty
litter box that's what this floor looks
like
him I actually have a Dust Buster good
point quick and easy you're out there
listening to their you know
Johnny Cash maybe the least right now
dustbuster is the uh the arch enemy of
daytime wait wait so he so he has a
problem with him them listening to
Johnny Cash
Johnny Cash which is maybe the least
right neck of the music they listen to
so what if the music's right who cares
they could be listening to Johnny Rebel
count your blessings that's a good point
but on the count of the black you know
family member they might not
do you hear the kids having fun
they're out there just just sing Walk
the Line and this asshole's in here
being miserable
what you are
sister out there standing kids knowing
flame well this is a house where
skinhead was beating her unit bro stop
it
the whole world doesn't stop because you
were made Believe beat up by your dead
brother
anything ever again because he would
times Sherman punched me in the shoulder
yeah exactly you know what it probably
was you know what it probably was
something as innocuous as a punch buggy
that Sherman did once write something
stupid like a punch buggy yeah and he
probably [ __ ] he like purposely flubs
the dates too they were probably like
teenagers when he did it he punch buggy
no return and he's a boxer and that's
not fair and it wasn't even a buggy it
was actually a Volkswagen van
a little bit [ __ ] hate this place I
hate these pigs absolutely
disgusting I can't even you know
celebrate my dad's birthday with them
why not because even though I'm mad at
him obviously as well
it's a participation of the entire
family
and you know staying completely neutral
and bowling maybe when I confront them
absolutely disgusting because they're
they're like living in the present and
every time you come up with your 10 year
ago [ __ ] they're like tayton you
gotta stop buddy we're having fun
it's on his birthday you can even go
downstairs in my own house on my dad's
birthday
you can you're choosing not to because
you're you're just an unsocial prick
so he's complaining that he celebrate
his father whom he hates birthday yes
he's complaining because all they want
to do is celebrate the birthday and he
wants to bring [ __ ] up like Roy said and
they're just like no
oh oh he might get to caught again hold
on hold on hold on hold on hold on just
come on
he's secretly filming a sneak increased
I know I haven't done it I got to do it
I gotta do it
because my younger brother that's his
younger brother who looks um what's the
word normal
he looks like a normal person just like
a normal person
to speak to me or even no because you
know why Dayton because he's hanging out
with his little nieces and nephews
instead because he's not a it's just you
who doesn't want to be around anybody I
like that you're just getting exacerated
you
just oh
he's Progressive levels in Seattle
he's a progressive liberal who lives in
Seattle but he still doesn't pass the
virtue test for Dayton hibernough of
course everything that happened over
here ignored all of my Outreach would
only occasionally reply maybe have some
excuse as to why it'd be okay for about
violence to happen to me well it's
because you thought you were lying and
you've already visited the nut Hut a
couple times from what I was told from
your family and like we've talked about
it the police know you and look I talked
to the producer of Dr Phil and he said
you were a little messed up yeah he did
we're friends with that guy we're really
good friends
he said it would happen to him too the
skinhead would beat him too and he
wouldn't take it personal that's just
the way he was but remember when this
first came out people were like when we
first covered this guy people were
sending Bibles to his house that was
weird
so that's just the way the skin had lost
it's absolutely sad
I don't speak in terms of any of these
people started speaking to him
but I love that he always says things
like I can't celebrate with them because
I'm not on speaking to him so you're
making this up though it's on you it's
all on you you could it's not that you
can't you just won't you don't want to
dad's birthday my brother my younger
brother has been in town since like
Friday and he has never made any
conscious effort to interact with me to
come upstairs in Iraq if he were to walk
upstairs and interact with you would
fall into a ball and the floor and start
crying
you would make a scene since he's
becoming more and more indifferent about
everything
is that the little brother there yes his
little brother normal guy upstairs and
say hi to me in the midst of all that
just a normal guy that's playing in the
background hanging out with his little
hanging out with little niece and
nephews
Dayton he's looking at you like like
yeah [ __ ] filming him like what are
you doing you
absolutely bigotry
and that's how the video ends
awful absolute bigotry
absolutely